in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on Deutsche Welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape joining us in
the studio today is Professor Tim and
grüner from the Institute of nutrition
at the University of Vienna hello to the
show hi and this man in the report says
that he feels absolutely healthy since
we changed his diet so can a vegan diet
really be so beneficial in fact you have
to be aware he didn't change only his
diet he did change his lifestyle this is
you changed his job he's different in
physical activity and the diet and of
course a change in lifestyle can change
also some or improve some let's say
unspecific symptoms like headache like
migraine like skin problems or so if
they are associated with a unhealthy
lifestyle before it's not always the
case but sometimes you might be lucky
but so it's the old package it's not
just attrition it's the whole package I
would assume so yes yeah so let's focus
first on the meat free aspect of it he
can died what could be the problems in
eating meat anyway okay so we don't do
know for a long time that too much meat
is not healthy for us on the other hand
no meat might also not be healthy so
that depends how balanced your diet is
after you remove the meat or all animal
products from your diet so it really
depends a little bit how balanced you
might eat after your restrictions so
it's not all meat is bad veggie is good
so that what could be some problems
associated safe--for with red meat for
instance
oh that meat we we do know that it is at
least associated with high calorie
intake fost might be certain types of
cancer that is an acid association and
we do not know whether it's a causal
principle
in these diseases but all
epidemiological studies shows that
here's an association between high meat
consumption and certain cardiovascular
diseases or cancer or perhaps a bit
obesity but the causal thing is you mean
that just meat-eaters are not so living
healthy on the other hand it might be a
yes but on the other hand not everyone
eating lots of meat is getting cancer so
it's an association and we do not know
the mechanistic all of meat in for
example colon cancer but if I would say
okay I I skip all meat and I stick to a
strictly plant-based diet are there any
risks involved in the plant-based diet
that there might be risk involved and
certain micronutrients are predominantly
present in meat or a better absorb for
meat products so there my especially
certain vitamins like vitamin D what I
mean a or minerals like iron and zinc
and what about the tox illogical effects
of pure plant-based diets I mean there
are toxins on plants out there they are
of course but in general if you consume
these plant-based foods in a normal way
like everyone in the population as
doings and you have safe on in terms of
toxins so what's it normally the normal
way is the normal amount and on the
other hand also the parts of the plants
which are assumed to be consumed as food
so if I put my carrots into the blender
I just put the carrots into it and not
the green stuff yeah just take the cards
before clean though yeah of course yeah
would you suggest any persons who should
not become vegans like pregnant women
for instance okay there are certain
parts of the population going children
young children elderly pregnant which
are which have certain requirements on
nutrition and it might be very very
difficult if you have a region diet list
like to get all micronutrients these
parts of the population need especially
for a second think about going to
children and calcium for
which they need for the develop normal
development of bones okay how healthy is
milk make us healthy first of all and
there are a limited number of adults
which have milk intolerance or an
allergy to certain components of the
milk and they of course cannot consume
milk but for all others milk is a
healthy normal component of our
nutrition and all speculations that
there are some difficult difficulties
with milk because it's not really sure
but about lactose intolerance I mean
those parts of Asian world have Yahoo's
interests but you know in a Western diet
it's normal and there are differences in
the genetics of the population so that
in Europe Northern Europe we don't have
so much milk intolerance lactose
intolerance so what about soybeans when
it comes to your health about the phyto
hormones okay
soy bean or soy as a nutrient component
is safe on the other hands there are a
lot of extracts now available on
isoflavones which has a fighter hormones
in soy and here you have to be a bit
careful because there's not no really
massive amount of data showing that they
are safe and on the other hand it might
be even that these fighter hormones are
ineffective for example and changing and
getting some effects so it's I would be
careful with them care of them okay so
we received a lot of viewer questions I
can only ask some of them but Arthur or
make it crack ooh from Ghana wants to
know something about eggs
what about egg and cholesterol how many
eggs are healthy for you oh that that's
hard to say because your cholesterol
level is determined by two components
one is of course nutrition and the other
component is your genetic disposition so
and a couple of years ago we didn't know
about genetic predisposition to high
cholesterol levels and blood and so it's
all about nutrition and therefore the
recommendation and strict limitation of
eggs as a nutrient on the other hand we
do know today
that there are certain genetic
variations that are associated with a
high cholesterol level in our blood and
you can't do anything about this
and for this persons I advise to go to a
doctor and ask about color stone could
you sing Serapis for all other healthy
homeowners are all others you would use
your cholesterol intake wire food and
since that 10 to 20% that you can manage
and therefore limit your amount of X
that you eat to two or three a week okay
two or three per week is fine yeah at
least the germinal recommendation isn't
that way so what about gluten you got
another viewer question from Canada's
still and Miller and she's got a
daughter who's not gluten sensitive but
she wants to cut out gluten out of her
diet just for health reasons and she's
not gluten sensitive so is it sensible
to do this I would say it's not very
sensible it's more difficult because
gluten you have in a lot of different
foods and therefore it's not a difficult
to restrict it and if you are not
required to it's a lot of pain it's a
lot of pain you don't have to go through
thanks so much for us do you took thanks
you